hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
taten welt ich hab heute ein kleines
präsent für euch aber heute sonst viel
mehr um verbraucherbildung gehen und
zwar bekomme ich ja täglich neue
zuschauer und bekommt dementsprechend
auch sehr viele e mails und nachrichten
über facebook und instagram und youtube
und meinen job wirklich über alle kanäle
und da erreichen mich eben nicht nur
e-mails mit rezept anfragen sondern auch
e-mails muss eben ganz speziell um
besondere lebensmittel geht zb um vegane
ernährung oder um vegetarische ernährung
aber es gibt ja auch menschen die sich
einfach besonders ernähren müssen weil
es ihr körper einfach nicht anders
zulässt
und so habe ich jetzt beispielsweise
ganz viele e mails auch bekommen zum
thema glutenunverträglichkeit und eine
dieser e mails hat mich ganz
nachdenklich gemacht deswegen habe ich
mich auch dazu entschlossen jetzt hier
drüber ein video zu machen und die e
mail stelle ich euch das mal vor
hallo liebes ali ich gucke deine videos
schon seit mehreren wochen und freue
mich immer total wenn eins von dir kommt
ich habe seit dem achten lebensjahr eine
krankheit bei der die haare ausfallen
und daher trage ich da ich mich ohne
unwohl fühle
und das im alter von fünfzehn nicht so
einfach ist eine perücke
zudem wurde vor drei jahren festgestellt
dass ich zur jagd habe also
glutenunverträglichkeit und das ist
ziemlich schwierig für mich denn
getreide kommt so gut wie überall vor
nachdem ich dann den kanal gefunden und
abonniert habe habe ich angefangen
glutenfrei zu backen und meine mutter
unterstützt mich in allem seitdem backe
ich so gut wie täglich denn beim backen
kann ich ausschalten und meine krankheit
für ein paar stunden vergessen und mich
nur noch dem rezept widmen
das gibt mir kraft und eine so positive
art färbt man total auf mich ab und ich
werde richtig glücklich ich backe seine
rezepte richtig gerne denn sie sind so
unglaublich einfach und lecker und du
erklärst das so toll dass man da
eigentlich nichts falsch machen kann
es würde mich freuen wenn du mir
antwortest liebe grüße deine nele das
war jetzt eine von vielen e-mails die
mich tagtäglich erreichen und ich habe
mich natürlich dann auch mit dem thema
beschäftigt weil ich kannte es vorher
nicht weil ich einfach selbst nicht
davon betroffen bin und habe mich dann
einfach mal hingesetzt und im internet
recherchiert und habe auch gesehen dass
es hexen riesen großes thema ist und
deswegen habe ich mir natürlich auch
einen experten gesucht weil ich kenne
mich einfach damit nicht so aus wie
jemand der das wirklich weiß und habe
einfach mal verschiedene firmen auch
angeschrieben und es war auch wirklich
äußerst schwierig weil kaum eine firma
zurück geschrieben hat außer die firma
scheer wo ich mich jetzt herzlich dafür
bedanken möchte weil die mich einfach
mit informationen ausgestattet haben und
ich wollte wirklich so ein überblick
über das thema habt und ich habe auch
noch eine andere experten die wir dann
am ende des videos sehen aber ich möchte
es einfach mal wissen was wissen
eigentlich andere menschen über das
thema deswegen nehme ich euch mit und
ihr durch jetzt euren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich stehe hier vor dem globus markt im
wiesental ich habe mich dazu
entschlossen das ganze hier zu filmen
weil um die mittagszeit in waghäusel
einfach kein mensch hungrig sind alle
hier einkaufen oder sind arbeiten und
hier ist auch der einzige ort an dem ich
drehen doch an dem tag genehmigt hat und
außerdem fühle ich mich hier richtig
wohl weil es da mein zweites zuhause ist
wie er ist und ich gehe als einfach rein
und sprechen einfach fremde menschen an
vielleicht kenne ich auch den ein oder
anderen aber das ganze ist ziemlich
spontan und ich hoffe auch dass ein paar
mitmachen und sich drehen lassen
aber das wäre jetzt einfach zusammen
herausfinden wollte mir einfach
[Musik]
dieses ziel vielleicht was für tennis
ich habe schon mal davon gehört aber ich
hab mich mit dem thema nicht mehr
also haben sie wahrscheinlich auch gar
keine kriterien und verträglichkeit
nicht bekannt ich stehe hier vor dem bio
regal machen wir natürlich ganz
besonders gut gefällt und habe ich
jemanden gefunden
kennst du dich mit gluten auf etwas wo
man allergien entwickeln konnten bei
unverträglichkeiten habe im weizen drin
ist oder im jahr begleitet und umgesetzt
davon betroffenheit und dem
bekanntenkreis raums zum glück ja ok
vielen dank gerne also jetzt
sonderumfrage die tätigkeit hätte lust
mit einfachen über antwort
es gibt so was zu machen
das ist okay aber sonst erste frage er
weiter über das motiv ist
bedeutung
und wir machen freie darum
für den hit du eine
lebensmittelunverträglichkeit
mitbekommen geschäften meist leider
nicht ich hab schon davon gehört ja aber
ich habe mich noch nicht damit
beschäftigt beziehungsweise kommt für
mich nicht in frage weil sie gar nicht
weil mich das nicht gut ist kann sie den
zaun steigende lebensmittel
unverträglichkeiten ein kurzer
bankenretter können ja viel spaß über
1000 danke ihnen für die wsd in baku ist
es gar nicht so ein akutes thema mit der
glutenunverträglichkeit die meisten sind
ja gar nicht betroffen was ja eigentlich
sehr gut ist aber ich gehe mal noch
weiter uns auch noch andere wissen sie
was pläne und sind sie betroffen selbst
ich nicht aber meine tochter okay
stationen als beispiele und wie macht
das wäre tochter bemerkbar
ihre geht lieber die nachsitzung und
kriegt natürlich da nie so hoch stand
schon okay außer magen darm technisch
das ist manchmal autofahrer und was
machen sie genau dagegen
ja natürlich muss man beim kochen sich
darauf einstellen
besondere produkte weil das ganze ist
versteckt meistens unter lebensmittel
und naturprodukte oder die dann halt aus
gesehen wo halt das mittel nicht drin
ist und wo bekommen sie die produkte
gibt es dann ja globus natürlich hat
auch im sortiment ja und verschiedene
abonnements zu kaufen bekommen
wissen sie denn was gluten ist ein
blutig
bitteschön eigentlichen 15 auf
sommerfrische gluten also automatisch
etwas anderes etwas mit wein zu tun
ja hier viele denken es werfe dasselbe
wissen sie macht euch mal kaufen ja
höhere ihr seht ihr übrigens sie selbst
gemachten drohte ich bin total lecker
hier und jetzt aber mal ob der spanier
ist mit dem habe ich hier neulich meine
praxis spanische auch schon
ich mache mir heute ein bisschen der
umfrage über die themen und bisschen
freier lebensmittel jetzt meine erste
frage des guten oder guten kann man als
sportler aus blut urin oder blut ab oder
weniger fein raus das thema kind ihn
fragt man sagen kloten okay geht beides
vielleicht die nächste marke ihr aktie
hier das vorurteil raum und poppig hat
der bäckermeister übrigen sich dass der
stadt bäckermeister den nicht kennen der
sowohl tolles code backen kann als offen
also denken auch treffen kann auf
frank schätzing und habt ihr hier gleich
auch die zehn freie waffen oder ist die
feuchten thema das ist ja mal gesehen im
regal vorne gibt der produkte aber gibt
es hier in der bäckerei auch hier auch
ein freies brot so mache aber 38 in
dieser sache komplett getrennt von der
eigentlichen produktion gemacht werden
das kann ich jetzt einfach am besten
[Musik]
hier haben wir jetzt nicht so gut
rüberkommen komplett eingeschleust
wieder sind das ist nicht so
selbstverständlich also wie kommen die
produktion muss komplett getrennt und
der rega weitgehend komplett gerade raum
getrennt sondern schädigt bei den
kranken menschen bei den betroffenen den
bin da und hier gilt man nicht
vermischen also weiter hoffen in allen
produkte und unser brot wo das hier
hauptsächlich mit reismehl mais und soja
melden und wirklich das was produziert
haben wir hier ja mal froh wenn die
lebensmittelabteilung ich sage nichts
regelung
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt unsere regale sind alle
ok und ich hab jetzt sehe ich hier
einmal gehen
foto ikz kuchen und kekse das heißt wenn
ich ihr rezept kann ich's medien im
katholisch und wenn es einfach machen
werden nämlich aber den tod
steht man mit dem plan nicht ganz so
gibt es auch das richtige rezept
super dann nämlich das ist zwar mit und
probiert es aus danke florida ich bin
jetzt mit meiner umfrage fertig habe
jetzt mal mehr gekauft aber ich glaube
es natürlich eine expertin die sich
damit auskennt ich habe nämlich noch
nikotinfrei gekocht oder gebacken aus
ich habe eben kein weitzel mehrere
nutzen deswegen stück ich das jetzt
einfach war einfach mal zu meiner
expertin
[Musik]
hallo
ich bin jetzt in meiner experte und zwar
ist das diana und anna ist die expertin
weil diana selbst betroffen ist
anna was machen wir heute hier
wir machen heute party brötchen dazu
hamamelis schon vorbereitet es gibt auf
dem markt sehr viele verschiedene
mischungen hat er hier schon was
gerichtet genau damit die von cherry
jetzt mal mitgebracht wusste nicht ob es
richtig oder falsch war immer richtig
gibt verschiedene hafenmarkt und wenn du
möchtest kannst du dir schon mal hier
rein gerne und ich habe hier noch diesen
aufsatz die getreidemühle und zwar
musste ich selber auch gar nicht dass es
so etwas gibt von kitchenaid und zwar
habe ich mich jetzt vom kiez jedoch
ausgelegt das habe ich jetzt zur
verfügung gestellt bekommen und hier
kann man zum beispiel auch das eigene
mehl mahlen
das machst du ja auch hier ja wir haben
hier schon reismehl vorbereitet aber sie
mir nachher auch zeigen dass man dann
mit dem hier noch das ganze ergänzen
können oder im prinzip auch eigenes brot
nur mit selbst gemahlenem mehl machen
können okay dann nehme ich jetzt den
aufsatz mal weg weil das ja schon
vorbereitet und wie viel mehl ist das
jetzt da wo sie jetzt 500 gramm
wenn einem so sieht das ist sehr einfach
es gibt jetzt im prinzip wie
französisches baguette fuchs mag er
kommt jetzt noch mehr hefe dazu man kann
auch eine frische hefe nehmen wäre dann
halber dürfen ja müssen aber darauf
achten dass sie bluten frei ist die
these aus melasse basis und auch jeder
auf weizen basis also auch damals machte
was man nimmt immer trockenhefe ich die
immer durch hinein nein man muss egal
was man einkauft muss man immer darauf
achten dass es wird bis zu 10 2 ist okay
ich sehe auch gekennzeichnet oder woran
er würde ich das jetzt erkennen es gibt
von der deutschen zöliakie gesellschaft
extra bücher wo man sich registrieren
lässt und das kriegt man dann jedes jahr
geschickt und da kann man dann erkennen
was kann man kaufen und was ist
gefährlich
so hier kommt jetzt noch zwei teelöffel
salz dazu mache ich einfach mal so ja
das kann dann jeder machen wie er möchte
die idee viel salz wolle mache es
gehäuft die andere lieber nur flach und
in samaria 400 milliliter wasser und der
der schon sich mit brotbacken auskennt
der weiß dass das sehr viel ist und das
muss man aber so nehme mir habe hier
reis mais kartoffeln und das heißt die
brauche viel wasser wenn man schon mal
reis gekocht hat dann weiß man nämlich
das reich sehr viel wasser braucht also
immer an die rezepte halten
ok und das gebe ich jetzt einfach ein
sondern lasters verkneten genau das ist
es schon eigentlich super einfach und es
gibt jetzt ein ganz toller tag
ok
und das ist der unterschied ist muss
richtig stehen fallen muss richtig
miteinander verbunden seien und deswegen
habe ich ja hier alles gewicht der wird
nachher dann richtig raus der löffel ach
ja und das ist das problem dabei viele
menschen denen sich die wähler weide
dass die meinen sie müssen noch meldete
und dann passiert was derzeit echt und
herzlich
und wir brauchen auch kein wasser in
baku war sowie süßigkeiten ist ja das
sieht es wird sehr schön es sieht
eigentlich aus läden betreibt genau so
aber ich denke dass der zeichen und
jetzt nehmen wir hier die zwei läufe
es ist natürlich möglich hier auch als
baguette ist zu machen oder als große
brötchen aber gerade jetzt festigkeit
hat jemand ein ist es natürlich schnell
gebacken ja weil mir brauche für kleine
kultur nur 20 30 minuten für die größere
brötchen liegt immer bei 35 bis 40
minuten und wenn man baguette machen
noch 50 bis 55 minute aber mit der hand
von ich mit dem kleinen also wenn wir
das gleiche jetzt als dampfnudel gemacht
hätte dann hätte man das rezept
verändert aber dann müssen wir wieder
ganz anders arbeiten aber das land mal
alles damit unsere kurse die den schabak
und kochkurse denn auf und ich habe auch
schon mal durch deinen kochbuch
geblättert schön und das gibt es ja auch
zu kaufen
in der hand habe ich auch schon
durchgeblättert und da sind natürlich
auch kratzer die basis rezepte trennten
früher teig bis mittag nahezu alles
mögliche durch ganz nah frühling sommer
herbst und winter komplette menüs und
alle rezepte sind dann drin von brot
backen
das weihnachtsgebäck und auch vorspeise
hauptspeise steige ich die grundrezepte
so eigentlich okay von der kunst ja du
brauchst nicht solange deutschland lief
einfach drauf ja das ist eine ganz tolle
baguette backform und einfach mit folie
aus gegner ja das ist der faden schlauch
hat den vorteil der iss bis 260 grad
einsetzbar und wir haben den vorteil
mehr braucht es nicht einfällt wir
müssen die leute denken mit
laktoseunverträglichkeit habe meine
frage was noch beim als rezepte von mir
macht und zum beispiel habe ich ja auch
schon biskuitteig oder rührteig gemacht
kann ich jetzt einfach das mehl eins zu
eins ersetzen
woran merke ich überhaupt das hotel und
verträglichkeit habe die zeigt sich
leider sehr unterschiedlich der eine der
mehr gar nix und der total der darm ist
die damen zerstört und der nächste hat
schmerzen
ok ich würde jetzt auch die symptome
einfach mal unten in der infobox
reinschreiben kann man es aber auch
nachweise hat und das jetzt hier 1000
leute kamen sage ich glaube ich habe mit
ihm und verträglichkeit
ja es gibt die möglichkeit blut
untersuchungen machen zu lassen es gibt
die möglichkeit in kliniken sich
wirklich von kopf bis fuß untersuchen
lassen
es gibt hier verschiedene gruppen es
gibt einmal die genetisch bedingte
krankheit die zu allergie es gibt die
allergie und es gibt dann auf die
unverträglichkeit das heißt er wirklich
ein riesenthema ja jetzt einmal die
möglichkeit gucken wir jetzt hier noch
im rennen vorbereitet die kann man jetzt
nehmen und kann die zum beispiel jetzt
einfach noch so ein bisserl drauf
drücken
einfach genau und so hätten wir das
jetzt mit olive machen können und es
schmeckt super gut er hätte jetzt
olivenöl mit
gewürzen so südländische gesetze drauf
machen können dass sonnenblumenkerne
sesam mohn und schon haben wir immer
wieder andere brötchen
wie lange müssen die jetzt bei wie viel
grad gebacken werden ich war generell
heißluft 190 grad
und hier die wäre jetzt 30 minuten
ich würde jetzt aber hier diese ganze
sacken bisher mit wasser noch bis 100
rätsel weil es wird schon sehr fest beim
backen
das heißt die könnte sogar die 100
wir haben uns damit endeten schauen wir
uns die drei mal an zu riechen zu
schmecken bestimmte auch die
messeleitung sind abkühlen lassen aber
das ist ja auch ein paar reiche wenn ich
sehe ja das ist ein körnerbrot die sich
sehr beliebt geschmacklich wie eine dies
aber kein auto drehen das erzeuge mir
durch zusatz melodie zum beispiel hier
mit dem reinsten demonstriert sieht ganz
normalen auswahl war das brot gutes
thema mit der vierten und
verträglichkeit im hotel ich natürlich
sehr komplex und zeitlos und das kann
man jetzt in diesem einen video gar
nicht alles behandeln deswegen falls ihr
noch informationen möchte und euch das
interessiert lässt er einen kommentar
dann würden wir auch gerne von video
zusammen machen das hat spaß gemacht
übrigens mit dir
und natürlich stehen auch ganz viele
informationen hinter ihnen verbockt und
man kann ja auch die kurse übergeben das
werde ich auch machen weil ich sie auch
sehr schön findet die ganze einrichtung
sehr liebevoll ausgestattet und da wird
muss nicht wollen
ja ich würde mich freude die ich dann
auch wieder hier zu begrüßen jeden fall
habe ich auch bei gut dann bis zum
nächsten mal bis bald
[Musik]